well you know my friends were like real
immature and stupid and wanting to party
and hang out and I'm on a path I no
longer care about people laughing at me
or laughing with me I'm just out there
having the time of my life look chase
your career but make sure to have fun
I'm brave you're not you need to get
rave I am NOT the monster boss
I do trust take suggestion well when I
first got the talkshow I was naive
enough to think that you know oh my gosh
you know we can get this celebrity and
that celebrity and this celebrity in
that celebrity she's an American media
personality actor author comedian and
daytime talk show host she hosts a
nationally syndicated TV show the Wendy
Williams Show she's created an
autobiography and several other books as
well as launched several products
she's Wendy Williams and here's my take
on her top ten rules for success number
ten is my personal favorites I'm curious
to find out which one you guys like the
most I I worked for Miss Hughes for
about eight months and I got in a
weekend gig in New York so I would do
weekdays at WOL in Washington and drive
up on Fridays after my shift which would
end at 7 o'clock and I'd be on all
weekend long over in Queens that's where
the radio station was located and then I
would drive back to DC and I would never
even stop at my parents house never had
time for friends because everybody was
kind of not understanding my dream and
kind of laughing at me or something or
trying to you know my friends were like
real immature and stupid and wanting to
party and hang out and I'm on a path and
my parents were very you know who do you
want to meet what is this crazy thing
you're doing called radio I would sleep
in my Subaru they gave me a Subaru for
college graduation and I I would sleep
in my car at every rest stop between New
York and and Washington DC to block out
the noise of people telling you you
can't do it right I would literally be
I'd have a blanket an alarm clock and a
quilt and I would take a bird bath in
the bathroom might be woken up by the
man suite
next to my Subaru looking at me because
I'm like the crazy you know girl in the
and I had a baby shade without a baby
pull the baby shade down you know and
that was my life for about two months I
was going back and forth no I think the
secret to the success of the Wendy show
is it starts from within you know I've
got terrific producers terrific audience
Department you know people shady
cameramen a terrific
you know lineup of co-hosts in my studio
audience and of course it starts with
the host
I no longer care about people laughing
at me or laughing with me I'm just out
there having the time of my life and you
know it doesn't matter whether a dress
makes me look fat if there's lipstick on
my teeth
you know I rub yes if my wig feels
crooked you know what I will tweak it
you know I the secret to the show
success I believe is authenticity and
the authentic me is messy Wendy from
Jersey but messy is good but when you
start it out I mean the Deb Mar mercury
they were the company that saw the
vision yeah because you had a couple
miss starts yes right there were other
show opportunities that didn't work out
tell me about that well you know you get
telephone calls from you know I I mean
I've had walking meetings with Sony and
and Wayne Avista Disney and and people
like that and I've done a few pilots but
nobody really knew what to exactly do
with me and also I was not confident
enough to tell them what to do with me
do you know what I'm saying right but
now they wanted to fit you into a mold
but but then when you were given the
freedom to be able to be who you truly
are that's when you explode it well I
was ready to be fit into a mold to like
tell me what you want me to do I just
want to be on TV I'm young Wendy from
Radio but the time Deb Mar mercury came
along in 2007 fall of 2007 I knew
exactly who I was and what I wanted out
of a TV opportunity I didn't just want
to be a host I want to be an executive
producer
and that means that I'm not just
somebody that you're gonna fit into a
hole right I'm going to dictate where
the hole goes and how it goes down now I
want suggestion from everybody but be
very clear you know I want to you know
the way I manage is through maturity
fortunately Bryan and young lady this
degree of success has come to me at a
time in my life where you know there's
no more excess of anything and I no
longer feel it necessary to leave my
show and go have a girls lunch something
like that I feel as though it's
necessary to leave to pick my boy up
yeah take them to another place go home
and make dinner for my family and
another happy place yeah your main happy
people I enjoy taking care of home and I
also enjoy a good night's sleep
and I enjoy I enjoy the peace in my head
that was not there for so many years as
well it shouldn't be you know the time
to have fun especially if you're in your
20s look chase your career but make sure
to have fun yeah when life gets serious
and life gets real there is no time to
be out until 2 o'clock in the morning
and missing the alarm clock and being a
responsibility learn in your partner I
have a terrific team to propel me
because I can't do this by myself
you know and I will not discredit myself
you know I I've done a lot of work to
get here and nothing's been handed to me
but to to stay here I've had to line
myself with the right team what's the
key to your success do you think
stick-to-itiveness you know I I ride it
until it can't be ridden anymore I have
a terrific manager who's my husband and
I've had some really fortunate business
relationships regarding broadcasting you
know Detmar mercury produces you know my
talk show and they have just been really
wonderful you know as you know we're
going into our seventh season
and as you also know a lot of great
shows actually get cancelled quick and
brian says I'm about to enter college
and a very passionate about reaching my
goal and become a jerk becoming a
journalist but I'm afraid to fail I keep
worrying about how I will achieve my
goal and what if it doesn't happen when
you started out in your radio career and
when you started developing started to
develop your your show where are you
afraid of failing and if so how'd you
deal with it because you're afraid to
fail you're in your own way you realize
that don't you
everybody has a certain fear of failure
whether they admit it or not of course I
was afraid to fail in radio of course I
was scared that this TV show wouldn't
work out um but I'm brave you're not you
need to get brave and don't tell people
that you're scared they'll use it
against you I mean you told me Brian but
don't don't tell anybody that you're
scared and you're afraid to fail people
look at that as a sign of weakness you
know good luck as a journalist because
if you're gonna be so scared then you're
plenty of other people who would love to
be in your spot as a future journalist
don't let him win you know failure is a
part of life are you kidding me
how do you balance so much how do you
balance having such
your social life your family all of them
it's a different kind of enjoying
yourself when you get older as a young
girl before I got married I owned
property
I had cars I lived a luxurious life in
fabulous out like I was a bachelor reg
my dance card was full I had boyfriend
fight I had a life when a career is not
gonna keep you warm at night and money
everything
at least that's what I said if you asked
Wendy yeah that's what I saying and I
only know that because that's what I
live by as a host yes either you have it
or you don't
it's not something you can learn in a
college classroom it's not something
that somebody can media train you you
know either you have it or you don't
and people say I have it but it's more
than that you know I've got a terrific
staff of people there you know almost
200 people who work at Wendy when I
count everybody who from cleaning an
office to a secretary to a cameraman to
my producers my executive producers and
they're wondering everyone knows their
job and I am NOT the monster boss I do
trust take suggestion well if I thought
if there's something that is being
suggested to me that they want me to do
and I say I don't want to do that okay
well all right wait come back tell me
why when I first got the talkshow I was
naive enough to think that you know oh
my gosh you know we can get this
celebrity in that celebrity and this
celebrity in that celebrity you know
just chalk the you know the show full of
celebrity culture and what ended up
happening was because I was a new girl
you know on television you know people
come to New York and they're going to
the usual places that they feel
comfortable they're going to Kelly and
Michael or you know Jimmy Fallon and
stuff and so they won't stop being at
our show so what we have to do is make a
better show around celebrities and and
we have and hot topics the hot topics
used to be eight minutes and now it's
20 23 minutes for even the first
commercial and every Monday is an all
hot topics show and we we had to make
lemons into lemonade because we were the
new show and it turns out lemonade days
are my favorite days thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Arlene dee asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I also love
to know which of the top ten rules had
the biggest impact on you and why leave
it in the comments and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching and to me to believe and I'll
see you soon